this isn't esoteric this isn't some
gigantic build it is but it's about what
happens to ordinary people conversations
around those kitchen tables that are
both profound as they are ordinary how
do i cross a bridge in the snowstorm
what happened no i
didn't think about it you know you're in
a situation what happens if the bridge
collapses and there's a fire on the
other side it's going to take 10 miles
longer to get to the fire people can die
i mean this is real this is real stuff
that's your president indulging his
first love for slam poetry doing his
avant-garde freestyle spoken word
routine how do i cross a bridge in a
snowstorm what happens if the bridge
collapses and there's a fire on the
other side tiger tiger burning bright in
the forest of the night what a mortal
hand or eye has framed thy fearful
cemetery
applause breaks out brilliant
what does it mean exactly
someday we'll understand for now we
don't deserve to know but we can be
certain of one thing a trillion dollars
of newly printed money for quote
infrastructure is a very good thing come
on man it's good
that's what our president is telling us
the downside of course is that inflation
is about to make you a lot poorer
inflation is what happens when a
government devalues its own currency
something the bid administration is
doing at a faster rate than in any time
in american history net result you may
make more money but you can't afford the
staples you used to buy because suddenly
everything is much more expensive
think of it as an ever accelerating
treadmill in the end inevitably you wind
up in a heap on the ground
but don't worry
it may be painful but it's going to be
good for you it turns out you are too
rich as it is you are weak and decadent
and flabby you've had it too easy mr and
mrs america why can't you be more like
our guatemalan grounds crew and quag
grateful and uncomplaining and
non-english speaking well that's the new
message from cnbc which has taken a
momentary break from committing a
natural sex acts on technology ceos to
lecture the american middle class about
their undeserved affluence
listen
the dirty little secret here willie
while nobody likes to pay more on
average we have the money to do so
household savings hit a record high over
the pandemic we didn't really have
anywhere to go out and spend
so the dirty little secret is
thanks to joe biden you can afford
inflation
so shut up
msnbc agrees with that quote why the
inflation we're seeing now is a good
thing they ran that headline recently
and then according to bloomberg news as
inflation rises americans quote may need
to gasp live more like the europeans
that actually might not be a bad thing
got it
so you're no longer going to have enough
money to drive your own car but honestly
middle america that might not be a bad
thing
you're going to love living like a
romanian it's fun to have less food
they're literally saying these things
out loud
just like louis xvi did and his wife
just like the romanovs just like batista
what is it about decadent ruling classes
that they always double down just as the
grotesque and unfair systems they've
created start to topple
they never see it coming
it's almost like they're stupid
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else